pushing democrats to blow up
long-standing senate filibuster rules so
that his party can ram through so-called
voting rights legislation the plan would
nationalize elections and republicans
are blasting it just as a desperate ploy
to help democrats in the midterms
jim crow 2.0 is about two insidious
things
voter suppression
and election subversion
i've been having these quiet
conversations with members of congress
for the last two months i'm tired of
being quiet
today
i'm making it clear
to protect our democracy
i support changing the senate rules
whichever way they need to be changed to
prevent
a minority of senators from blocking
action on voting rights
at consequential moments in history
they present a choice
do you want to be the sign the side of
dr king
or george wallace
what a puppet
but guess who couldn't be bothered to
show up stacy abrams and other left-wing
activists decided to snub biden's event
the activists saying they've had enough
of speeches and photo ops but biden
doesn't seem to think there's any bad
blood between him and abram's listen
are you insulted she's skipping the
speech i'm gonna totally ask the
question
i spoke to stacy this morning we have a
great relationship we got our scheduling
mixed up i'm going to be i've talked
with her at length this morning
we're all on the same page and
everything's fine
dana do you get your scheduling mixed up
with the president of the united states
i would say like if when the president
of the united states says i'll be there
tomorrow at 10 you drop everything so
that you can be there especially if it's
your signature issue yeah this is the
issue remember she never
conceded that she had lost in the
georgia election and she's been
traveling the country on a speaking tour
to try to drive this message home in
fact arguably she has done a lot more to
try to advance this issue than biden and
harris have done and now at the last
minute because build back better didn't
work out and the left wing is freaking
out and you have michelle obama weighing
in you have the administration without
ever having
let given the american people a speech
about like why this needs to happen
today when the president says i'm tired
of being quiet he yelled the entire time
and while he's doing that the naacp for
example they're putting out statesmen
saying you haven't done enough so
here's what's going to happen once again
strategically they've over promised they
are going to under deliver
midterm elections are about turning out
the base
the ba forget about the republicans
being in opposition like the fact that
the democrats can't even work together
on this and that stacy abrams in georgia
had a scheduling conflict
i can't imagine what that phone call was
like between you know ron clayne perhaps
the chief of staff in stacy abrams
office
and then i'm sure that biden and stacey
abrams had a nice little chat today but
she you noticed she didn't change her
schedule i mean what was so pressing
that you couldn't be there with the
president today last thing i would point
out is there's some students in arizona
and one of the colleges who have said
they're going to go on hunger strike
until
this law is passed and the filibuster
has changed so keep your eye on that oh
god i hope they had a big dinner before
they announced that
greg maybe stacey abrams was writing
another one of her erotic novels oh god
couldn't be bothered i have all of them
at home
original copies i might add
anyway you mentioned at the top of the
show about how i mean this just seems
ridiculous in light of everything else
that's going on in the country yeah and
you know i mean it's just great
when he mentions george wallace because
whose side was george wallace on he was
on joe biden joe biden bragged about the
fact that george wallace liked joe biden
uh i don't know why the activists are so
upset about joe because moderate joe is
dead he's buried uh what you got it you
what you saw up there is some
guy who wants to federalize elections
he's splitting the country in half with
divisive ear splitting rhetoric like a
dementia riddled transient shouting at
clouds
i mean
and it's all for something that uh i
don't think he's going to be able to
pass with 48 votes speaking of which how
can he keep redefining majority as
minority like how does one side with
more votes
than you become a minority i don't get
that and what voting rights are we
talking about denying as far as i know
if you're an american citizen and you're
of a certain age you can vote i mean
unless you want to get really specific
is he talking about a murderer who
doesn't have an id because i want to
know
who we are denying how hard why is i it
sounds to me that we're all about
getting it easier getting people to vote
getting it making it easier and now
finally we got to look at our republican
patsies who got played by the dems with
this january 6th anniversary i'm
wondering next year how are they going
to use january 6 again what catastrophe
will the next anniversary feed into will
they be able to ban forms of speech
because of january 6 will they be able
to force more crt in the schools because
of january 6. every year we're going to
get to look forward to
the use of january 6 as a ploy to create
a scared population to scare them stupid
so that they're actually on the same
wavelength as joe biden
daniel mcdowell
i like greg's point this is like
joe biden and company are not reading
what happened today
this is when you invite a lot of folks
to a party and it's scheduled at a very
convenient time it's right after work
you just got to come by right on on your
way home you know it's it's right it's
on the bypass you just you know i live
in an apartment it's next door to your
office building you can comment i've got
punch i've got white cloth whatever you
need
nobody showed up to biden's party and
i'm sure that they anticipated what he
was going to say bringing up george
wallace can you ima i mean they would be
standing on stage with a steaming
flaming sack of joe
him talking about george wallace and
then who as
greg pointed out uh well he was a
democrat but biden once bragged about
you know
wallace paying him a compliment
and then and then he always brings up
like the ed edmund pettus bridge named
after uh grand dragon in the clan joe
biden gave a eulogy a little more than a
decade ago for an exalt excu excuse me
former exalted cyclops of the clan
robert byrd so he constantly reinforces
the fact that he is old
and used to be friends
with racists and segregationists
and the lie geraldo from biden is that
these states crack down on voting no
they didn't they just made it harder to
cheat easier to vote and harder to cheat
well jesse i think that what happened
today was a pretty good speech that got
wasted uh yes the volume was uh was all
the way uh you know was nailed
unfortunately but the language dagger at
the throat of democracy turning point in
the course of the nation you would think
that this was really really an important
thing but what is voting rights really
about i mean i bet most of us and most
of the people watching right now have no
idea what exactly is in this legislation
i do can i read it too it's really about
well good all right here we go homework
i'll read it it eliminates voter id
election day starts two weeks before
election and then you get an extra week
to count the votes so election day is
actually three weeks they mass mail out
absentee ballot applications makes it
harder to clean up the voter rolls and
you don't even need a signature
on your absentee ballot all right and
although he's my favorite hold on hold
on this is my personal favorite you're
allowed to serve food
at a polling station can you smell the
barbecue geraldo i mean i would vote
democrat if i was so hungry
just because you've got a prime time
show doesn't mean that you get to glom
my time on this project do you have all
the time the fact of the matter is what
is this about this is about
mail-in ballots
trump lost because of mail-in ballots
because the regulations were loosened
because of covid so you had a huge flow
of mail-in ballots i don't know if they
were legitimate or not i assume they
were legitimate most of them because of
the various reviews that took place so
it's about that and it's about voter id
as a member of a racial minority and
also 10 native american i resent the
notion that people like me
are too incapable of getting a voter
identification getting an id card why
don't why doesn't everyone in this
country if you're talking about
nationalizing elections if nationalizing
elections means that everybody gets a
voter id maybe with your social security
card number written on it everybody
should have an id everybody in this
country should have an id and if you
have an id you should be able and you're
a citizen in this country and you have
the residency requirements uh
established you should be able to vote
now mail-in ballots the problem with
that is harvesting ballots and if they
send them to everybody you're going to
have some slickster going door-to-door
and saying hey molly did you fill in
your mail give me your ballot oh you
didn't fill it in i'll help you fill it
in it's hard that's the danger right and
i think the republicans are right to
oppose well this is a pro harvesting
bill and and it's not going to pass
and that's a fact hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else